what is going on everybody welcome back
to the cosmic wonder where we talk all
things marvel and mcu i'm your host
warren thompson and today we have some
pretty good news about the big bads of
marvel's next phase the big bads in the
current mcu are something that a lot of
fans have really been wondering about
since we don't really have one yet we
have had individual bad guys in the mcu
projects that we've gotten so far but
none that are actual big bads big bad's
that not just one hero but multiple
heroes have to join together to actually
defeat so far each movie in marvel's
phase 4 has had their own personal
villain and the same goes with the
disney plush shows their own personal
villain but it is about to go down big
time in the mcu and phase 5 and phase 6
are going to be incredibly exciting
because the big bads are coming and they
are about to be introduced very very
soon and hopefully that means that we
get introduced to our new avengers team
or another team in general doesn't
necessarily have to be a new avengers
team it could be the fantastic four it
could be an x-men team it could be an
illuminati team for all that we know but
here's what you need to know about
marvel's next big bad which is kang now
i'm assuming most people know that king
the conqueror is about to be a pretty
big villain but i don't think people
know just how big he's going to be now
first off kang is going to be debuting
officially and fully and ant-man and the
wasp quantum mania now something else
that you might not know however is that
he's not going to be the only villain
for ant-man 3. we've talked about this
before on the channel but it is widely
believed that modok is actually going to
be a big villain as well in quantum
mania and i know a lot of fans are
really really excited about this and i
actually think that modok himself is
going to be a big bad as well not just a
villain for one movie now of course kang
is not a villain for one movie make no
mistake about that there are going to be
multiple different versions of kang this
was set up very clearly in loki and of
course loki season 2 which is filming
right now is also going to be addressing
king however we don't know which version
but let's start off with ant-man and the
wasp quantum mania version of kang
according to the good old rumor mill
modok is going to be kind of in charge
of kang he's going to be the person that
employs kang so this variant of kang the
conqueror that we are going to be seeing
in ant-man 3 might be a little bit more
tame but here's something that you need
to know about kang the conqueror a lot
of people are worried and are saying
that there's not going to be a better
villain in the mcu from here on out than
thanos thanos was peak villainy and
there's no way to top him however i
disagree i think kang is actually going
to top thanos because you have to think
about who exactly king is and you have
to remember the events that happened in
loki one let's not forget that now there
are going to be many many different
versions of kang evil versions of kang
he who remains who is king the conqueror
even said at the very last episode of
loki if you think i'm evil well wait
till you meet my variants the kang
variants themselves caused the
multiversal war just variants of kang
the conqueror variants of nathaniel
richards which was his original name
kang variants alone not a bunch of
different teams not a bunch of
incursions by doctor strange or any
other member of the illuminati or the
avengers no just kang the conqueror
fighting himself and then one of them he
who remains came out on top and defeated
everybody else then he created the tva
to control everything so then in loki
when loki went to court he said that he
wasn't to blame but it was actually the
avengers that were to blame however the
tva said that that was supposed to
happen the avengers were supposed to do
all of that the avengers were supposed
to go back in time they were supposed to
collect all of the infinity stones from
the past go back to their present time
and defeat thanos the tva made that
clear that means that the tva allowed
the avengers to defeat thanos that means
that the tva allowed thanos to do
everything that he did and who is in
charge of the tva kang now originally it
was he who remains that was in charge of
the tva but now at the end of loki since
the tva has kind of changed it is
actually under a real kang the conqueror
not he who remains not a tame variant of
kang but an evil variant of kang we know
this because where there used to be
three statues of time keepers in the tva
it is now only one statue of king the
conqueror so yes thanos was an amazing
villain and the infinity saga was
fantastic infinity war and in game are
two of the greatest movies of all time
not just marvel movies but of all movies
and i'm not trying to take anything away
from that but kang the conqueror let all
of that happen and now we are dealing
with a villain who can kind of control
time and can multiverse hop so this is
going to be on a way bigger scale but
taking it back to ant-man 3 we're still
probably going to be getting a rather
tame version of kang i do not believe
that this is going to be the kang the
conqueror in fact i don't think there's
ever going to really be a the kang the
conqueror one king until the very end
because keep in mind the multiversal war
between all of the kangs is going to be
actively happening so not only are we
going to be seeing our heroes go up
against kang but we're going to see
different variants of kang go up against
each other i'm guessing that some are
actually going to be good some are going
to be kind of in the middle but some are
going to be absolutely ruthless a great
example of that is of kang ruling the
tva at the end of loki season 1 and then
the fact that kang in ant-man 3 is going
to be working for modoc means that he's
not yet reached his full potential there
but like we've been talking about
eventually this will go on to lead to
secret wars and the main villain of this
is going to be kang now he might be
sharing that role with doctor doom but
make no mistake kang is going to be the
big bad of the multiversal saga
incursions and multiversal war is going
to be taking place during phase 4 which
we have already actually experienced and
then phase 5 and phase 6 and however
long they want to go until they
eventually bring it to secret wars now
we know dr doom is coming and he's
coming very soon and what i actually
like about this is that we'll probably
see kang or a few versions of him work
with doctor doom but we know doctor doom
and he's definitely going to want to
take kang's technology and eventually
use it for himself but i think kang is
going to be getting a little too
powerful at some point in time which
means dr doom will have to kind of work
with the avengers and the fantastic four
and any other team that may be fighting
but of course dr doom really only does
this until he can kind of get what he
wants it's just a way for him to get
what he wants and doom has been known to
fight alongside of some of our avengers
in fact one of my favorite story lines
is where him and doctor strange go to
the hell dimension and take on mephisto
but the biggest thing to be aware of
here is that kang the conqueror is going
to be an incredibly huge threat and is
going to be a villain unlike anything
that we've ever seen before even thanos
thanos had the infinity gauntlet which
was fantastic but kang literally has the
ability to control time also not to
mention king has the ability to know
everything that's going to happen we saw
this in loki he had the full script of
everything loki and sylvia were about to
do now eventually we came to a point to
where everything got new and he didn't
know what was going to happen however he
is not in charge anymore a new variant
of king is and i'm actually really
excited to see a ruthless king control
time and fight our avengers also side
note since modok is going to be in
ant-man 3 i'm assuming aim is in the mcu
now we just don't know about it and if
that is true i'm definitely guessing
that aim could be behind the dodc the
department of damage control doesn't
really make too much sense why are they
interested in superheroes why are they
so hostile towards these people with
powers and ever since miss marvel
started the dodc was giving me major aim
vibes i honestly thought that they were
going to be the true villains of miss
marvel and i'm still kind of holding on
to that however i think the final
villain will indeed be comrade but i'm
still going to be waiting for a reveal
that says that the dodc is actually run
by modak but we'll have to wait and see
on that but in the meantime let me know
what you think about kang the conqueror
and not just one big bad but multiple
big bads that are actually different
variants of kang let me know your
thoughts about this in the comments down
below don't forget to like the video and
subscribe so you don't miss out on any
of the latest mcu news for live updates
you can follow me on instagram and
twitter and as always thank you all so
much for watching woof